you know that they've come out now and
said that president kennedy was killed
because he was going to release
information on this yeah that's what a
lot of people say
so that's a popular belief well and what
they did was and this and the way came
up with this
was supposedly there's a burn document
that was found i want to say like
six or seven years ago and somebody
would turn it in
uh to a mufon group and it talked about
what is what is mufon uh mufon is the
mutual ufo network okay they were
created in the early 90s
to kind of be that group that really
kind of investigates hey what's going
really
going on with no agenda they had no
agenda just really kind of find out what
the truth was
so as this group started to mature
obviously
listen it got bigger and bigger and
bigger now like i said when
i've actually submitted some some film
to these guys on hey what am i looking
at here what is this thing
so they're a huge organization now i
mean a monster organization
and they have um now
implemented some programs with david
greer
to who is dr david greer who was our
stephen graham
who who was the uh guy responsible now
for kind of bringing this
this whole thing to the forefront with
it with the 40 people that he brought
one of the guys that was there talked
about buildings being on the dark side
of the moon
he was a he was in the navy he had a top
security clearance he said that when
they brought him in and he was going to
be handling
video and film that came back from
combat missions and he goes he got
he got brought into a room one day he
said the guy said stay here
wait right here i'll be right back and
he said i hadn't even gotten my my
clearance yet
and he goes so i'm standing in this dark
room where they're developing a film the
guy says hey man you want to see
something really cool come over here
so he's like oh okay so he goes i'd go
over there and check it out and he
starts showing me buildings on the dark
side of the moon
and he said to me these aren't ours
so aidan that's your [ __ ] cue bro so
when you start looking at that you know
again going back and kind of looking at
the bigger picture like what so this guy
can't be lying i mean is he
would he really get up here would all 40
of these people have such fantastic
stories
that um you would say no this guy's
lying
the one guy that talked about 40
different creatures that were coming
here 40 different aliens or 40 different
terrestrials et's were coming here
the one of the former prime ministers of
england
said the u.s has been dealing with a
group called the tall whites for like
the last 15 or 20 years
i'm pretty sure this is the conversation
that got a shadow banned so
that's probably what it got a tall white
hole rockefeller
the rockefellers are in control they
don't want us to do that the tall whites
are they're
um is that the one for men in black no
explain these guys don't know about the
tall whites we gotta we gotta educate
these
these newbies on the tall whites the
tall whites were a group of very nordic
looking
extraterrestrials very tall light hair
just very very big
there was some talk that in the early
30s
that there was a guy that was basically
his name was
thor and he was a tall white and he was
working within
the senate in congress so if you look
him up online and you pull him up
this guy looks like um a very tall
nordic slack jawed
you know just a really good looking
human being or alien whatever he is
like a viking like more like a viking
than anything else like something on the
rumplements logo
yeah very cold i mean but again
at the time yeah at the time when this
guy from
from canada came out he said hey
i don't know look up tall whites now
we're talking about tall whites yeah the
fellow whites do whatever we're talking
about just trying aliens
and they're aliens but he said that you
know ufos were as real as planes to fly
over your house
i mean there he was just he said there's
no denying it they're there you know we
know they're there
whether the government wants to talk
about it and i think again you know in
the bigger picture
that if if the planet let's just say the
these are the tall whites
elon musk there we go others talk about
it but
that's okay see the blonde next to them
that's that's really kind of what they
say they look like right there
now i see our boy up there at the top
yeah
right go to that one up there the other
next one over nope right there
edward snowden edward snowden you think
he's a tall white
so well i mean listen he's he's living
in russia right now and i'm sure they're
going to let him stay there as long as
he can continue to
tell them secrets because once he runs
out of secrets he's coming back to the
u.s yeah they're going to send his ass
back
i don't know i don't know i don't think
he i mean he's definitely not going to
come back to the u.s because he's going
to go to prison if he does well it's
just it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a
choice
yeah it wouldn't be they would the
russians will hand them over go as a hey
i know you guys want this guy so here
we're your friends i think the russians
are keeping him are letting him sit
there and be safe and be comfy
because it's kind of like a [ __ ] you to
america i definitely go with that
i definitely go with that for sure they
um like i say i think that they think
they've got the upper
upper hand with having a guy like him
yeah so i mean i've listened to him talk
he's definitely
a smart guy definitely an intel guy for
sure yeah
you know is he playing the game probably
um
but somebody somewhere is dealing with
and i think this is how it works out i
think each country
has found a ufo and i think that each
country is kind of doing what they do
to develop that information as quickly
as possible
and i think whoever's running the show
is kind of watching that trying to
figure out okay who's my best student
here
who's really the smartest of all the
groups do you think it's like an episode
of shark tank where they're just like
waiting for the best investment
i do i do i think i really think there's
a couple things going on and i think we
talked about this last time
i think that when you go back and if you
look at humanity and how many times
we've been wiped off the planet
and you're back on the planet and wiped
off the planet again um and whether this
is through
natural selection or if it's through the
great flood or if it's through
uh some sort of virus or disease or
meteor
meteor whatever it was would kill
everybody off and then all of a sudden
somehow the earth would repopulate and
so
today there's more people on the planet
today than ever recorded history
why is that and i think if you look at
one thing that has changed
more so than anything it's it's the way
that we develop
and you know cast out from our cars all
the carbon dioxide
the planet likes carbon dioxide the
trees like
carbon dioxide so i think that we
became so good at that that that's
really what they wanted so i think we're
kind of like a bacteria i don't think
you know it's the same way as if we see
a bug on the ground we kind of look at
it and walk over it i think they kind of
do the same thing with us
and i think they monitor us though to
obviously see what the health of us is
you know you
want the bacteria to keep doing what
it's doing and i think when you look at
at kind of the history of mankind i mean
we live near the water
we overpopulate we destroy everything
you know if you look at a good virus or
a good you know
toe fungus you know and pretty soon all
of a sudden it's the toe fungus is
taking the nail off
and i think that's kind of what happens
here and i think so they start to watch
that
here recently in egypt there now let me
back up about
40 years ago in the sinai desert they
found this green glass
and they couldn't really figure out
where the green grass came from other
than the guys who were
head of our nuclear program here back in
the states knew that when they set these
bombs off in vegas
in los nevada that they
right near the center of where the blast
was the sand would melt
it would turn green so they came back
and started looking at the rocks
like well i mean check this out they
found
one of the on king tut's um coffin they
found this
green beetle and they couldn't figure
out where this
green beetle came from where'd they get
this stone from
and they said it's definitely from you
know find the green beetle
4 000 degrees what it takes to to melt
sand so it's an
it's obviously a big event that takes
place
the egyptologists have always said well
it's a it was a meteor strike
well i mean the ancient alien guy is
like okay well where
where did it hit well you know the sands
it can carry can cover up everything
they cover up pyramids so they kind of
had okay we'll take a back seat to this
um four weeks ago they found
a carved picture of what looks like a
bomb
i mean just like the a-bomb if you look
at the remember what the a-bomb looks
like
it's a guy dropping it from his hand and
on the left side or on the right side of
the pitcher is this mushroom cloud
so they just found this so now the
egyptians are going aha
well you know it's too peculiar and i
think if you look i think those pictures
are up there too i think i gave you
those pictures
yeah so they also had um uh spaceships
that were on there
or extraterrestrial crafts that were
looked like your traditional saucer
that they outlined as well so
um three weeks before that
they found these hands they were steel
metal hands they found 16
pairs that were 3 600 years old
so it's these type of things that make
you go well hold on a second man
all right well all right let's do this
how do you know they're 3 600 years old
[Laughter]
yeah